[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
ian rappaport nfl network national
insider
sorry about that ian can you see a
situation man not gonna lie
all all right well you work with eisen
so you're worse you're used to
hearing that um now why did i do that to
eisen i
had no business doing that to eisen um
best in the business
yes yes so he's told me uh
the cowboys situation can you see a
situation where
they start to mail this in that they
will truly give up on the seat could
jerry jones possibly do that
see i i don't know how really any team
could do that you know
we've heard this before we've heard the
dolphins we're tanking for tua and
you know now it's like the jets tanking
for trevor and
you know i i think about it all the time
because every year it comes up in some
form or fashion and you know for the
cowboys
i mean they're looking like they're
gonna get a high pick now
just based on the way they're playing
the problem is individual players don't
tank right players are playing for the
jobs they'd like not to get cut
they'd like to score touchdowns and get
sacks and do all the things on the
football field that are positive
so individual players aren't tanking
coaches are not tanking because coaches
would like to
i mean i don't think mike mccarthy would
like to be one and done i think he'd
like to win some football games and get
this thing right
so i don't see tanking as an actual real
thing however the direction they're
going
probably will do it anyway i mean the
cowboys have shown not a lot of optimism
that probably at this point seems like
they're going to be starting garrett
gilbert
on sunday which you know it's not
tanking obviously but
he's not the greatest quarterback that
gives the america's team the best chance
to win
on sunday so there's a lot of factors
that are leading toward that i just
don't think it's on purpose well you've
seen the jacksonville jaguars where
gardner minshew is being benched
yeah i know jackson this feels like
managerial tanking to me
i i actually felt like the the move to
jake luton
who seems like he's in line to start on
sunday is probably more
from the coaches than anything just they
would like to
get some wins and i think gardner
minshew stats are okay
his moxie and other football things are
good
he just hadn't played great throwing a
bunch of interceptions fumbles
i mean for all the optimism that we had
about gardner minshew heading into the
season
he has sort of stood up to none of that
i mean he's
he's struggled the team has struggled
they're playing from behind all the time
i think this is more the coaches trying
to get a win apparently jake luton looks
great in practice i guess both the
quarterbacks glennon and luton look
better than minchu in practice
so it's more the coaches being like we
need to get a win somehow to save this
thing
maybe this is the guy to do it so
they're kind of taking a shot with him
why is this game being played tonight
right so i guess that's the big question
that everyone has now you have multiple
coveted issues on both teams you have aj
dillon
uh for the packers testing positive you
have jamal williams with a close contact
and now for the 49ers you have kendrick
bourne you have trent williams who's now
a close contact
uh it is and brandon iok also one of the
bright stars this game not playing
the reason it's being played is because
no one else is at further risk
so you have the covet issue with the
packers you have the close contacts go
away
no one else is test deposit for the
49ers you had one positive
they are able to examine the close
contacts based on the connexxon
bracelets that the players wear
to see exactly who could possibly have
been
in close contact with them and so you
isolate those guys they are out and
everyone else is deemed not at risk
so you're missing some big time players
but you play on because it's 20 20 and
nothing is perfect
and no one is at further risk yeah but
we move the patriots game it's not like
this would be unprecedented to move it
to sunday
would moving it to sunday be a little
fair to both of these teams
i'm just not sure why uh i mean first of
all they both are you know
for packers it's running backs for 49ers
it's receivers so it's like they both
have
in a weird way it's it's kind of even
but the rules changed a little bit after
after the patriots game was moved right
the nfl went to a little bit of a
stricter protocol they isolated the
high-risk close context they did a
better job of saying
instead of all right we're just going to
push the game and we're like all right
which individuals are at risk remove
those guys
keep testing and then we can play
because in the end
the nfl wants everything safe first of
all and then on schedule
and it's not perfect but it seems based
on who's missing on both sides kind of
fair
so they will play on what do you make of
bill belichick
being a little sensitive to the patriots
struggling and he blamed it on
we went all in those last five years
winning super bowls going to
a super bowl losing going to the afc
title game what
what is he saying and who is he saying
it to
i i liked it and i know that he's
getting some criticism i've read it
um i appreciated it because one
when bill belichick talks the business
of football there's nobody better so i
like the fact that he's actually
instead of like monosyllabic answers
after a press conference i like the fact
that he's actually
explaining right like we ask these guys
questions
you want an answer it could
theoretically come out as defensive i
just
if it's defensive and explaining i will
take the explaining part
um i think he's right
because last year they did spend right
up to the top in cash
i also think they you know this is a
year where they got
they had no cap space literally none all
they could afford was a can you know cam
newton one billion dollar plus contract
and then they got a little cap room due
to some settlements including the aaron
hernandez settlement
then they had all the opt-outs and now
they have a ton of cap space but nobody
has spent it on
so they lost the players couldn't
replace them because
you know who are you gonna who you're
gonna spend the money on there's nobody
out there
so it's a actual rebuilding year for the
patriots which they've never had
and they'll clear all the cap space and
next year probably kind of start new and
we'll see what happens at quarterback
but potentially the new quarterback as
well
yeah i can't imagine cam is back unless
we see
a drastic turnaround here it feels like
they've already you know they have their
opinion on jared stidham
now you got to either go in the draft or
free agency
what kind of possibilities are out there
for the patriots to find
another franchise quarterback yeah i
mean
if we'll see what the record ends up
being i'm of the opinion that the
patriots are always going to be fine so
i'd be
surprised at this point if they are not
like eight and eight
seven nine because they're always
they're always fine right but we'll see
but if they have a high draft pick could
definitely take a quarterback i mean
that's
that's something we have not seen for
real for real since jimmy garoppolo
uh and that was a late two so i think we
could see that the options
if they don't take one in the draft
there there's not a ton of them
but sam darnold would be potentially one
depending on how the jets would do now
that would take the jets trading their
former franchise quarterback to the
patriots yeah
i don't know i guess we've seen crazier
things but
you know i mean i don't know and then
you know the rest of the guys you're
looking at
are franchise guys who may not be in a
great place for their team
matt ryan probably stays kirk cousins
contractually
probably stays uh phillip rivers is that
toward the back end i mean there's just
not a lot of great options the one that
i think will get all of us talking is
jimmy garoppolo because you know if he's
gone
that's an option that could be a win-win
for both that kyle shanahan gets his
quarterback
whoever that is if if it's matt ryan or
kirk d cousins
um and then bill who loves him some
jimmy garoppolo
can get garoppolo back and that might be
his franchise quarterback
i thought about that and i think that's
one thing you'll hear a lot
is is jimmy garoppolo going back to the
patriots the only thing that gives me a
little pause about that
is he didn't play a lot for the patriots
right like he only played i think two
games
he was in the building for a while and
when belichick called the
49ers about trading for him he said
okay i think it two is about right so he
valued him
as a second round pick back then which
to me
he's a quarterback getting traded for a
two that
if he thought he was a franchise
quarterback no matter what he would have
said we need a one for this guy that's
my only thing that gives me pause about
him reuniting with the patriots still
could make sense i'm just
i'm just kind of curious about that part
of it yeah but i don't know what was
going on behind the scenes if you know
brady wanted him out
and bill had to make that decision
of do i bet on the future do i bet on
the president and he wanted to keep tom
keep tom happy
and therefore hey if i hold out for a
one i might not get that one
i know i can get the two i can i can put
him in you know
great hands with kyle shanahan and the
49ers
i i don't know it felt like that that
was belichick doing garoppolo
a favor and doing tom brady a favor as
well
that's a really good point i mean
because if he says all right i need a
one then he might just not be able to
trade him and i think the point of that
for belichick's standpoint was just to
to get a good clean deal done
rather than like you know haggle back
like just is it
is it two do you want it yes or no they
did do garoppolo a favor by sending him
to a great place
all that is true i think looking back
now
you know whether or not brady actually
really wanted him out
i've never proven i've heard the
suggestion i've just never proven it
i've never had anyone write on the
inside say yes brady want him out
i just think for the patriots once brady
stopped aging
once he basically was like i'm going to
play until i'm 45 and i'm still going to
be good
then their only way to get real value
was to trade them then
that's that's they hedged their bets by
keeping garoppolo for half a season they
were like the only way we're going to
get value
trade them now we have to do it that's
my recollection of how it happened
what's the deal with the trade deadline
that should have gotten done
i think will fuller probably should have
gotten done
you know he is he's an electric talent
he's not always been on the field but
when he is he's awesome
packers could use a big play receiver to
kind of take them over the top
um the texans wanted a two if the
packers came to the texans
right at the deadline and said you know
the dante fowler deal will do it for a
three and a five
that is a tough decision to turn i mean
that's a tough pick to turn down
right so i don't i just don't know that
it ever really got to that and i
thought from where both sides stood that
they should have come together and done
a deal was jj watt ever in play
no i don't think so i mean i don't you
know those are deals made by owners
um not well they don't even have a gm
right now but not
they don't have not interim people you
know
um it's not deal done by jack easterby
who's kind of filling in and running
football and those are done by owners i
never got the sense the owner would
trade him
and i never got the sense jj was like
you need to trade me i think he wants to
be there
he would just like the football team to
be better is michael thomas playing
sunday night against the buccaneers
it's looking that way not for sure for
sure because we did this two weeks ago
and then he pulled a hamstring and
in warm-ups and then didn't play for two
weeks but ankle's fine
hamstring is getting better sounds like
emanuel sanders is probably back
so we will actually see the saints team
as they should be now they've still won
games they just haven't looked the same
i think michael thomas is
probably back sunday yeah feels like
there's more to this story
there are there there has been a lot
there um
i would say it has not always been not
always been kumbaya
uh there's been you know when you have a
fight in practice and punch a teammate
um there's some feathers that get
ruffled along with
faces or whatever assuming unless he was
wearing a helmet which
whatever anyway um yeah i mean i think
behind the scenes there definitely
has been some conversation and
potentially some some things that needed
to be settled
but i never got the sense it was
something that was insurmountable
ian thanks for joining us we know you
have a busy week and uh we'll be
watching this weekend thank you very
much
all right always happy to hang with you
take care that's ian rappaport nfl
network
national insider uh you can see him
monday through fridays
on nfl now at one eastern also follow
him on twitter at rap sheet
nfl week nine kicks off tonight nfl
network fox
prime video with the packers niners
that's at 7 30
eastern